hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
a novel method for the isolation of
highly pure
carcinoma cell populations from ffpe
tissue
improved sensitivity for detecting
somatic mutations
i am sabrina lemus of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by miltoni
biotech
to learn more visit www.dot.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question
box located to the far left
of your screens this presentation is
educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker karina
emery
the product manager for sample
preparation at miltoni biotech
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top
of your screen karina welcome you may
now begin
your presentation so today i'm going to
talk to you guys a little bit about
we have a really great novel solution
for using ffpe tissue for genomic
analysis
uh before i get start get too much into
the details of that
let's just take a minute to talk about
what
is ffpe tissue so ffpe stands for
formalin fixed paraffin embedded and
it's a common method used to preserve
tissue specimens for histological
analysis
so the way this works is first the
tissue specimen is fixed in formaldehyde
next it's dehydrated in a series of
increasing concentrations of an organic
solvent like ethanol
and then finally it's embedded in a
paraffin wax block
the block makes it easier to cut slices
for mounting on
a microscopic slide this method of
preservation
enables biological specimens to be
stored at room temperature for years
and often decades the minimal cost
required to store sspe tissue has
resulted in the accumulation of vast
archives of ffpe tissue blocks
it's been estimated that over 20 million
ffpe blocks are archived each year
in the u.s so while ffpe tissue has
traditionally been used for
immunohistochemical studies it's also a
very
valuable tissue source for genomic
studies of both rna and dna
this allows investigators to correlate
disease state and tissue morphology with
genotype and gene expression signatures
however working with fspe tissue for
genomic studies
does come with some challenges so before
we move on
let's go ahead and set some expectations
so there are some technical limitations
of working with fspe tissue the fixation
process causes cross-linking
of the dna the rna and the proteins and
this leads to fragmentation of the dna
and the rna
and denaturation of the epitope moreover
there's really not a global standard
protocol for preparing ffpe tissue and
storing ffte tissue
so the quality of rna and dna may vary
significantly from one sample to the
next
on the other hand a variety of
commercially available kicks have been
developed to standardize the molecular
analysis of ffpe tissue and have
um dealt come up with really clever ways
to deal with the fact that the rna and
dna from fspe tissue is going to be
degraded
and numerous studies have demonstrated
the utility of ffpe tissue for
genome-wide association
studies and gene expression analysis so
even though there are challenges to
working with sfp
tissue it's such a valuable resource
that we're coming up with more and more
innovative ways to take advantage of
this
so tumor is one of the most common types
of tissue found in ffpe archives
but molecular analysis of tumor is
complicated by tumor heterogeneity
in addition to having a diversity of
cancer cells tumors are also made up of
the surrounding
terrible cells such as vascular
endothelial cells
parasites fibroblasts and tumor
infiltrating the immune cells
thermal cells make up the tumor micro
environment and are genetically distinct
from the lineage of cancer cells
while cancer cells tend to accumulate
mutations over time
the surrounding stromal cells do not and
they maintain a genome
that is more comparable to germline dna
um so because of this there's some
issues with working with ffpe tissue
so the presence of non-tumor cells
within a tumor complicates genomic
analysis
because cancer-associated mutation or
gene expression signatures will be
diluted out by the presence of normal
dna
one way labs addresses complexity is to
compare the ffpe tumor dna to a normal
matched sample of dna
novel mutations that are present in the
tumor but not present in the max
normal tissue are considered to be
associated with the cancer pathology
however one of the problems is there's
often no max normal
tissue available for comparison of tumor
versus non-tumor dna
the lack of a max normal tissue is uh
considered an
obstacle to taking advantage of many
ffte tissue archives
so we're going to present our unique
solution today to help overcome this
challenge
but first let's review what methods are
currently used to deal with tumor
heterogeneity and ffpe tissue
there are three common methods for
enriching for tumor cells in ffpe tissue
each method relies on staining the
tissue sections
followed by microscopic analysis
typically a trained pathologist
will locate areas of the tumor and
normal tissue
and as you can see in our first slide
here they'll often do this simply by
just circling the tumor tissue on the
slide
so one strategy for dealing with the
fact that uh tumor samplers that are
going to be a mixture of normal in tumor
tissue
is to just simply accept the can
contamination
so you could not perform you could just
skip performing tumor cell enrichment
and by doing this you you typically are
limited to working with samples to high
to moderate percentage of tumor
cells uh because when the percentage of
tumor cells is really low
your ability to detect cancer associated
mutations is going to be compromised the
next
option that is quite common is manual
micro dissection
so this is where when after the
pathologist circles tumor tissues on the
side
a slide uh you would then go in with the
scalpel to selectively scrape off the
tumor tissue
um so macrodissection is effective
at removing a good amount of the
surrounding normal tissue however
it cannot eliminate any stromal cells or
immune cells that have infiltrated the
tumor
and that make up the tumor micro
environment so this infiltration of
non-tumor cells
into a tumor can be highly variable it
can be minimal or it could be a lot
so the effectiveness of micro uh the
effectiveness of macro dissection is
also going to be highly variable
so the last option is laser micro
dissection
so this is going to be a much more
precise option you can use it to isolate
single cells or larger areas of interest
under direct microscopic visible
visualization
while laser microdissection is very
precise and you can really selectively
obtain pure tumor cell populations it's
very
um expensive equipment and it's also
quite time consuming and consequently
low throughput
um so miltoni biotech has come up with
an innovative solution that is
faster and higher throughput than laser
micro dissection
but more effective than manual macro
dissection so it's kind of fixed in
between those two options
so let me introduce our method our novel
method starts with the premise that the
best way to separate cells
into different populations is to first
dissociate the tissue into a single cell
suspension
once the fspe takes place in a single
cell suspension
protein markers can be used to separate
out tumor cells from non-tumor cells
either by using slow sorting or max
technology
analyzing the tumor and non-tumor cells
as separate prop
populations not only enables increased
sensitivity for analyzing the tumor
mutational burden
but it also actually creates a max
normal dna
sample out of the same ffpe tissue block
so while disassociation of solid tissues
into
single cell suspensions is commonplace
for fresh tissue for applications such
as
flow cytometry and single cell
sequencing this has not really
been widely applied to fspe tissue and
multani biotech
is trying to change that with the
introduction of our ffpe
tissue disassociation kit this kit uses
genomax
technology to dissociate ffpe tissues to
create suspensions of single cells
and it's able to do so while in
preserving important epitopes that can
later be used for
cell separation now let's take a closer
look at how genomex
technology works
the gentlemax system combines mechanical
disruption
and enzymatic congestion mechanical
disruption is provided by the gentlemax
dissociation tubes
these tubes contain a rotor stator
system that gently breaks down the
tissue
enzymes are provided in a collection of
tissue specific dissociation
kicks these enzymes are highly purified
pre-titrated
and they digest the extracellular matrix
to yield
intact individual cells this is all
controlled by the instrument and its
collection
of tissue and kit specific programs the
instrument shown here is the gentlemax
octal with heaters
by combining physical disruption with
enzymatic digestion
genomax tecla technology allows for fast
and gentle tissue dissociation
because this can be done in a fully
automated walk-away fashion one can
reduce
hands-on time and decrease variability
as a result of tissue processing
the ffte dissociation kit is used with
the general max opto dissociator with
heaters to process
fixed tissue into single cells for
downstream separation
dna isolation and analysis this kit
provides the protocol
and all the reagents you need starting
from deeper
departurization going all the way
through dissociation
uh this standardizes the dissociation
process and avoids the use of manual
methods that can be
variable time consuming and less
effective
so by using this reproducible
standardized and fully automated system
you can process eight ffpe samples in
parallel
uh and this will generate single cell
suspensions ready for whatever your
downstream application is gonna be flow
cytometry flow sorting cell separation
or dna analysis miltoni has validated
this kit on a wide variety of
ffpe tumor types including breast
prostate
colon lung and pancreas now let's look
at the workflow
the workflow starts with a 50 micron
slice from a paraffin block
after slicing the section rolls up on
itself to create a paraffin curl
and up to two of these curls can be
transferred into a gentle max tube
this method will be less effective with
center sections because there will be
fewer intact cells and thinner sections
and no intact cells if the section is
too thin
to prepare ffpe curls for dissociation
the parasite is removed using the
organic solvent and xylene
and once the paraffin is removed the
tissue is rehydrated using multiple
ethanol washes
followed by final wash and distilled
water
the sample is then taken through an
antiderivative retrieval step so
it's heated at 80 degrees in a buffer
and this reverses the cross-linking that
was introduced by the formaldehyde
fixation
by reversing this cross-linking we're
going to improve the availability of
epitope for tumor cell enrichment
the sample is then processed using the
gentlemax octo with heaters
followed by filtration through 70 micron
filter
finally you now have a single cell
suspension that's ready for downstream
applications such as tumor cell
enrichment
um so we have demonstrated that the ffpe
tissue dissociation kit preserves two
very important epitopes for
distinguishing tumor and non-tumor cells
this is cytokeratin
and vementin
cytokeratin is a marker for epithelial
cells and it can also be used as a
marker for carcinoma cells carcinoma is
a type of cancer
that developed from epithelial cells
carcinomas are a very prevalent form of
cancer and account for
about 80 percent of all malignant tumors
carcinomas are often found embedded in
mesenchymal tissue
such as the example image of an ovarian
carcinoma here
thermal cells in tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes express the mesenchymal
marker vementin
whereas the carcinoma cells express
cytokeratin
and in the merged image here um all the
way to the right you can see the
lamentin
and cytokeratine staining are mutually
exclusive and
thus they're really good for separating
out carcinoma
cells from non-tumor cells
now let's look at some data generated by
miltenny's r d
team demonstrating how well this works
and how we can
use these markers to enrich for
carcinoma cells from
ffpe tissue
so looking back at our workflow we go
straight from separating carcinoma cells
from non-tumor cells
into dna sequencing however given that
this is likely a new method for you
you'd probably like to make sure that
the dissociation
and fell enrichment step worked first so
let's go ahead
and add a step to our workflow in order
to confirm that our two
tumor cell enrichment step worked
we used flow cytometry as an extra
quality control measure to confirm that
we've successfully isolated highly pure
populations of tumor cells
by either using flow sorting or max
technology
before we move on to the results let's
review the two options we have validated
for enriching for
cytokeratin positive ffte cells
the first option is cell sorting which
we perform by
staining dissociated ffpe cells with
cytokeratin
and vomentin reaffinity antibodies
followed by sorting on the max quantity
cell sorter
however this technique would work with
any cell sorter
the other option is to use mac max
technology which is a fasting simple
method for
separating cell populations by labeling
epitopes with specific antibodies that
are
conjugated to magnetic microbeads the
way this works is first a short
incubation step is performed
to bind the anti-cytokeratin microbeads
to the carcinoma cells
then the cell suspension is passed
through a max column that is placed on a
magnetic max separator
the labeled cytokeratin positive cells
will be held inside the column by the
magnetic field
while the non-tumor cells pass through
the column
finally the column is removed from the
separator
and the uh therefore the magnetic field
is removed from the column and the
cytokeratin positive cells are included
as the enriched posit positively
selected
cell fraction due to their small size
max microbeads do not need to be removed
for downstream applications so you can
go straight into flow
sequencing or whatever else you're doing
so now let's take a look at some data
here we have an example
of human choline carcinoma cells that
were purified from
a mixture of dissociated ffpe tumor
cells that were spiked into dissociated
ffpe
spleen cells uh we enriched this mixture
using the cytokeratin microbeads and the
cells were then fluorescently stained
with uh cytokeratin antibody and
vermenting antibody and analyzed by flow
cytometry
the graph to the left shows the cell
mixture before cell separation
and you can see that less than 10 of the
cells were positive through
cytokeratin after cell separation with
max technology greater than 95 percent
of the cells were
vital keratin positive we saw
similarly good results with cell sorting
in this example we collaborated with
investigators at the institute of
pathology
that at the university medical center
got engineering germany
and we analyzed ffpe pancreas carcinoma
tissue
after dissociation of the ffpe tissue
using
our tissue dissociation kit we performed
self-sorting based on
cytokeratin and vementin expression
using those two
antibodies before start before sorting
33 percent of the cells were cytokeratin
positive
while 44 of the cells were momentum
positive
after sorting the cell populations were
enriched to
over 95 and with excellent cell recovery
which is shown in the table here we then
extracted dna from the post short
population
from around 200 thousand cytokeratin
positive cells
we got almost two micrograms of dna
which is well more than enough material
for sequencing in other molecular
applications um so before we did
do sequencing with these samples but
before we even started that we went
ahead and checked the dna integrity
naturally we were concerned that a added
tissue processing step
involved in the fspe dissociation
process
might cause dna degradation so we
isolated dna from the same ffte
sample either with or without
dissociation
we then ran these samples on a
bioanalyzer to examine the quality of
the dna
recovered notice that the peaks of the
red traces appear at the same location
and are similar for both dna
isolated directly from the ffpe curl or
dna
isolated from the ffpe after
dissociation
this indicates that the ffpe
dissociation process
did not result in any additional hearing
or degradation of the dna
sample so now that we know that our
dissociation process did not affect the
dna
we then proceeded onto targeted envius
sequencing
using an in-view all-in-one onco panel
this table shows the results of the
frequency of select
uh of a select number of mutations from
targeted dna
sequencing of the pancreatic carcinoma
sample
we assess mutation frequencies for the
sample before dissociation
after dissociation but before sorting
and then we also looked at the two
sorted populations the momentum positive
cells
in the cytokeratin positive cells
please note that there are no
significant differences in the mutation
frequencies of the sample either
before and after dissociation
um you can see this in the blue and
magenta bar graphs
this demonstrates that the dissociation
process does not affect uh
mutation allele frequencies we then
looked at how separating the cells into
tumor in non-tumor population
affects these mutation frequencies
two mutations kraft e12b and
tp53r273h
showed a substantial difference in
mutation frequency between the
cytokeratin
and the menting cells
we expect the cytokeratine cells to
represent the tumor population
and the vementing cells to represent the
normal population
with dna comparable to the germline
interestingly both the kraft b12v and
pp53r273h mutations were virtually
undetectable on the vemmenting cells but
were present in the cytokeratine cells
at high
frequencies greater than 50 percent
this is a strong indication that these
two mutations are cancer-associated
somatic mutations rather than germline
mutations
if they were germline mutations they
would not necessarily be associated with
the cancer pathology
in this example um both of these two
mutations were present in the
non-dissociated
tissue at frequencies greater than 10
percent
so it is likely that we would have
detected these mutations without
enriching for cancer cells
however we just um as you can see
there's a lot of different mutations
there
we would have not always been sure
whether or not these were germline
mutations
or somatic mutations without having that
matched normal momentum
cell control however let's look at some
examples where the mutation frequencies
were not that high
so in that case not only do we get
assurance that
this mutation is associated with the cat
pancreatology
we also get increased sensitivity
in this study we collaborated with
investigators from the institute of
pathology at the university
at the university hospital cologne in
germany to examine the effect of
enriching for tumor cells
in samples with decreasing tumor cell
content
in this experiment we used ffpe tumor
samples resected from
non-small cell lung carcinoma pacing
a trained pathologist estimated the
tumor cell content of each of the three
specimens
and circled the tumor cell areas
so specimens one two and three were
estimated to have tumor
content of seventy percent ten percent
and less than
five percent respectively detection of
specific cancer mutations becomes
unreliable when tumor cell content is
less than ten percent
this is because typical ngs assays will
not reliably detect mutations with uh
when the mutation frequency
is much less than 5
so we took serial settings of each
specimen and then
enriched for tumor cells either by
manual micro
dissection that is when we selectively
scrape off the tumor from the slide with
the scalpel
or by using the ffpe tissue dissociation
kit
in combination with max technology to
isolate cytokeratin positive cells
we then extracted the dna and performed
engineer
and then performed ngs analysis using a
targeted oncogene panel
for each specimen we assess how macro
dissection compared to our method for
tumor cell enrichment for detecting
cancer mutations specimen one was
largely tumor cells approximately 70
and for the samples uh macrodissection
gave very similar results to our method
in specimen one we found a 52 frequency
of our driver mutation
whereas with our message we found a 60
frequency so not much of a significant
difference there
the differences became more apparent in
specimen two
because this sample only had 10 tumor
cells
we saw a much greater difference in the
frequency of the driver mutation between
methics
macro dissection resulted in an 11
percent mutation frequency whereas our
method resulted in a much higher 28
frequency and finally the most
significant difference between the two
methods became apparent in specimen
3 which contained less than 5 percent of
tumor cells
in this sample macro dissection only
resulted
in a one percent frequency of our driver
mutation
whereas our method resulted in a seven
percent frequency
uh going from a one percent to a seven
percent mutation frequency
is really significant because it's the
difference between being able to
confidently detect that
mutation that is present and not being
able to detect that
most ngs assays cannot reliably call a
mutation at one percent
so either this mutation would have been
missed or follow-up assays would have
been required to confirm it
whereas if you saw a seven percent
mutation you would have definitely
detected that with
high confidence
so we have focused on dissociating ffte
tissue for
nvs sequencing and have demonstrated how
tumor cell enrichment can really aid in
that
sequencing process and identifying of
cancer-associated mutations
but sequencing is not the only way you
can assess dna content of a cell
so let's look at another interesting
method
flow cytometry can be used for ploidy
analysis of a cell separa
of a cell suspension and we have found
that it works well on disassociated ffpe
tissue
refers to the number of chromosomes in a
cell and aneuploidy refers to cells with
too many or too
few chromosomes aneuploidy is common
in rapidly dividing cancer cells and has
been investigated as a prognostic marker
in several cancers in flow cytometry
ploidy analysis
involves staining the cells with a
fluorescent dye that binds to the dna
such as gapi or pi and then analyzing
the resulting data as a histogram
thought such as the one shown here
in this example we're looking at normal
healthy diploid cells
here the majorities of cells are not
actively dividing so you see
a large sharp peak of diploid cells in
the g0 or g1
phase for dividing cells you see a
smaller peak to the right that
represents
higher dna content as the cells are
duplicating their chromosomes in
preparation for mitosis this same
technique can be used to measure the
ploidy of the cell population as long as
you have a reference
diploid cell population for wrestling
the workflow for floyd analysis is
similar to what we did through
sequencing
first we dissociate ffte tissue using
the tissue dissociation kit with the
genital max octo with heaters
then we sting the cells with fermenting
cytokeratin
dappy and red blood cell marker cd235a
finally we analyze the samples by flow
cytometry on a max quant analyzer
we demonstrated polity analysis with two
fspe
samples a prostate carcinoma and a colon
carcinoma
the first dating step we performed was
to exclude red blood cells from the
analysis based on
positive cd-235-a staining
we also gated out non-nucleated cells by
the absence of dappy staining
as i mentioned before employee analysis
requires a reference diploid population
in this example we're actually able to
create our own reference population by
gating for
momentum positive cells in cytokera to
negative cells
uh conversely we're able to analyze the
tumor cells only by getting first
cytokeratin positive cells in fermented
negative cells
in the resulting dna histogram the
wrestling cells are shown as a green
trace whereas the carcinoma cells are
shown as the yellow trace
for the prostate sample the traces of
the carcinoma cells and the reference
cells are almost identical
this can be quantified as the dna index
which is simply the ratio of the dna
content of cancer cells to reference
cells
for the prostate sample the dna index is
close to one which indicates the
prostate carcinoma cells are not
unemployed
for the choline sample the traces for
the carcinoma cells and reference cells
are very different
for the colon carcinoma cells you see
two two peaks in spital one
the first peak peak one aligns with the
reference peak
this indicates that a portion of the
carcinoma cells are diploid
however the presence of the second peak
to the right of peak one indicates that
a portion of these cells have a higher
dna content than the reference cells and
so must be aneuploid
so as you can see this experiment
demonstrates the utility of the ffpe
tissue dissociation kit to generate a
max
control sample from the same ffpe block
when you don't have a max
normal sample available so that wraps up
all the experiments i wanted to show you
today
so i would just like to quickly review
what we
went over in today's webinar so the most
important thing to take home
is you can make a single cell suspension
out of fspe tissue
it's not well known but it's actually
very simple to do and we make it very
simple with our ffpe
dissociation kit um importantly when you
are dissociating the ffpe tissue if you
do want to do
downstream cell separation it will be
important to make sure that you are
preserving
your cell markers of interest and we've
demonstrated that we can preserve
the cytoskeletal markers of the mentin
and cytokeratin to separate out tumor
cells
uh or carcinoma cells from non-tumor
cells
we have also validated this workflow on
the analysis of dna
um so all of this allows you to reduce
tumor heterogeneity to get that more
sensitive
cancer-associated mutation detection
and it also importantly reveals uh
remove the need to always have
a matched normal tissue control with
your tumor samples which is not
available
in a lot of fspe archives
so that's all for today i'd like to
thank
everyone for listening and i'll now
open up for questions
awesome thank you so much karina for
your informative presentation
start we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we're going to
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
okay i see a lot of questions coming in
so karina our first question that i see
is um how do you know that you are fully
disassociating the ffpe tissue into a
single cell suspension
so if you're doing this in your lab one
of the easiest things to do is just to
look at it
under a microscope to confirm this if
you have access to a fluorescent
microscope you could do
a dna dye like daphi or hoax to confirm
that you only have
one nucleus per cell um the way we've
done it is by using slow psychometry and
we saw a lot of that data where you can
see
the clear cell populations that
show that this is an individual cell
with one copy of the genome
thank you okay so our next question
coming in
is how long an sfpe sample can be stored
and under what condition which enable
for
which i think they mean which can be
enabled for future cell isolation
um and will the fixative use influence
will the fixative used influence the
results
yeah so that's a great question i do not
have an answer for how long can an ffpe
sample be stored um
especially if you're getting it from
archival samples
you may have um fspe that had been
prepared a number of different ways
maybe not all in the same fixative
so the fixative used will influence the
results so we tested everything on
formlin fixed tissue um so
that is kind of one of those things
we're just going to have to try and
see so when we were validating this
protocol
we were not specifically pushing the
linux of fspe
age but you could definitely assume
within a few years it should be fine
oh i should also mention um it will just
to clarify it will not
work if the section has been used for
histology
so if you have an ffpe section on a
slide
that will not be compatible with
dissociation because those sections are
too thin
and won't yield any intact cells
great thank you karina um the next
question i have
is can these first steps be done on a
standard robotic
setup or does it need to be manual
we do not have any solution to do
the um we don't provide a solution to do
the first few steps which is deep
sea parasitization and rehydration
um in a robotic way however if you
had a solution for that it could
possibly be compatible
we suggest just putting the tissue in
the tube
um our gentlemax tube but if you have a
way of
transferring the tissue delicately from
your robotic system to a gentlemax tube
then you would be able to do that
robotically but again this is not
something we have a solution for
got it thank you um our next question
um can this be done for mouse tumors as
well
so the dissociation step should work on
any number of species
of and tissue types however
the um downstream separation is
only for human cytokerating so
you would have to then validate your
separation
on using a different antibody for
cell separation
great i would like to thank the audience
for all of these questions coming in our
next one
is why isn't germline mutations
associated with cancer pathology
unlike somatic mutations
i have to follow you guys for that i
think i was a little unclear
um in my uh text so
uh what i meant to say is that um
journaling mutations
can certainly be involved in the cancer
pathology but a lot of times when you're
looking at tumor tissue as a biomarker
for precision medicine you're much more
interested
in the somatic mutation so the mutations
that are only present
in the cancer cells because that helps
you more um
clearly define what therapy course to
take
okay the next question i have is can the
isolated
cells be used for downstream protein
extraction
that is not something we have tested um
however we do know some proteins stay
intact obviously we're using
cytokeratine and vinmentin
but it's just not something we have
tested so
you can certainly try
awesome thank you um let's see the next
one we have
is the key step is the enrichment of
tumor cells what is the efficiency
or the efficacy rather of enrichment of
fixed and non-fixed tumor cells with
your chiropractin antibody
so um if we were using
non-fixed tumor cells so i'm assuming by
non-fixed human
fresh live tumor cells we wouldn't be
using
cytokeratin we would need a surface
marker so cytokeratin is part of the
cytoskeleton and you wouldn't be able to
access it
um in live cells so
we have actually miltoni has a lot of
great
solutions for cell separation based off
surface markers alive cells i highly
recommend visiting our website we use
cytokeratin
um for fspe just because you do lose
a lot of protein signal when you're
doing this formling fixation then
uh dissociating stuff so we wanted to
use something that was like
really abundant and so that's why we use
these
uh these cytoskeleton proteins um
however
uh you it's certainly possible that you
could
look into other protein markers actually
i think that
is one of the next questions um so
yes the next question okay
can you look at protein biomarkers in
the sorted cells
yes uh so sorry if that wasn't clear um
a lot of so a lot of that data was
um for flow cytometry and we have tested
several different um epitopes and
protein biomarkers and the ffpe tissue
unfortunately as i mentioned
you do lose a number of them
um so we do recommend doing some
optimization and testing before
landing on your protein biomarker
especially for surface epitopes those
tend to be cleaved a lot
so i see one who uh one question where
they said they're specifically
interested in cd3 cd20 and cd138
we have not had a lot of success in
getting
um and preserving those surface markers
for downstream flow cytometry however
that doesn't mean it's not possible we
did not try
everything and i can definitely follow
up with you with some suggestions
got it and um have you attempted to do
single cell
rna sequencing from ffpe um dissociated
cells or have you tested any
optimizations to your ffpe
dissociation method to enable single
cell rna sequencing
that is not something we have tested
um i would uh if you were to go
down that path i would recommend
possibly optimizing the protocol
we do have that very long um one hour at
80 degree
antigen retrieval step which is very
necessary for
cell separation to get access to those
um those cells those protein cell
markers however you can imagine that's
probably not doing
uh a lot of health or that's probably
not helping the integrity of the rna
um so you would probably need some uh
optimization
of the protocol specifically the
antigen retrieval step and of course
your starting ffpe
sample would need to have decently
intact rna to begin with
awesome and do you have markers for
lymphoid elements
we do not at the moment we we were not
able to identify
any surface epitopes that worked um
although again i would emphasize that we
did not
try everything so um i don't want to
tell you that
everything is not possible but we did
not have a lot of success with surface
markers
got it on the next question i have
coming in is
um what were the tissue inputs and in
parentheses
core needle biopsies um resections
and tissue quantity that were used for
the experiments shown in this
presentation
so in this presentation we typically had
surgical
biopsies or resections for this tissue
i think it would definitely work with a
needle biopsy
you just might um depending on the
area of the tissue it's possible that
you might have to use
more than one fspe
section or curl in order to get an
adequate number of cells
great and we have time for one or two
more questions
um the next one is what is the duration
taken
for ffpe extraction using this
technology
um i think that question is asking how
long
is the workflow and it's about uh
roughly uh two and a half three hour
workflow
it's kind of the pain so we have the
hour long um
antiguan retrieval steps and the
dissociation
step is another 45 minutes and we have
washing steps so
somewhere between two to three hours
total
awesome and our last question for today
using this method can we isolate cancer
cells to find non-somatic cell mutations
well that was our exact idea for using
this method that you could isolate
cancer cells out of your ffpe tissue
so that you can um so
we envision people being more interested
in the somatic mutations than those
cancer cells but
if you then have normal tissue or normal
cells to compare it to
then you can also determine whether or
not
the mutation in that cancer cell whether
it was
germline or somatic
awesome thank you so much karina um
karina do you have any final comments
for our audience
um yes that we have a really great um
global technical support team so if you
guys um i'm sorry that we don't have
time to get to every question today
but please reach out to our technical
support team and you can find all that
information
on our website they're really great
they'll get back to you
and talk to you specifically about the
needs of your projects
and they can definitely answer any
specific questions about your
sample type so again i apologize we
can't get to everyone today
but definitely reach out to our
technical support team
thank you again karina for your time
today and your important research
we would like to also thank lab roots
and our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time
of registration this webcast can be
viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time stay healthy goodbye